[Music]
a monumental new biography of Thomas
Edison is set to be released this week
the author is one of the greatest
nonfiction writers of our time edmund
morris
who died this May at the age of 78 just
after the book was finished Edison a
colossal work of research and writing is
a raw and unflinching look at a man
whose inventions have shaped nearly
every aspect of modern life it is also a
stirring final act from Edmund Morris
[Applause]
walking through the Thomas Edison
National Historical Park is a trip back
in time machines commissioned by a mind
that produced the greatest inventions in
history the motion picture camera the
light bulb the phonograph what's insane
it's more than a hundred years old
it is almost incredible to think about
what Thomas Edison accomplished what
Edmund Morris does is explain how and
why what Edmund accomplished is amazing
because there are more than 5 million
documents and the Edison archives here
in West Orange and Edmund mastered this
body of material both published and
unpublished Leonard the graph is the
archivist at Edison's West Orange Lab
his team worked closely with Morris to
make sure the author had access to
everything from the laboratory of ta
Edison the archives this is where he
figured out the light bulb oh my gosh
his custom tools
this was Edison's Home Depot basically
yeah even the contents of Thomas
Edison's personal desk inside his lavish
library important visitors would come in
here Mark Twain was actually in this
room with Edison in 1888 DeGraff says
this facility set the template for how
innovation takes place in America
team-based research and developments
which companies like Google and other
tech giant's use today I would argue
that the research development laboratory
is his most important invention not the
light bulb no that's pretty fascinating
here
no question about it Edison let it all
with a punishing schedule often working
50 hour stretches sometimes napping on
his workbench for short breaks that
routine had consequences the personal
side of Thomas Edison has never been
examined the way Morris does it what
does edmund morris explain about the
Thomas Edison story that hasn't been
explained before Edmund is able to
convey the true nature who Edison was as
a person in a way that reveals the
aspects of his character that are less
favorable he could be cold Edison could
be cruel Edison had very difficult
relationships with his six kids and both
his first and second wife in part
because he was almost never home the
complications of the man in full became
the last work of one of the world's
great biographers his passing was sudden
very sudden yes and I think in our
entire marriage he only had two coals
Sylvia Jukes Morris is Edmund Morris's
Widow an accomplished biographer herself
the bound galleys of the Edison book had
just arrived this spring when Edmund
Morris collapsed inside the couple's
home in Connecticut all of a sudden I
hear this bang and I look up he's not in
the chair and I said oh darling I called
out did your trip
I have rushed over and found him on the
floor
and I picked up his head and he said Oh
a stroke just like my father had and
then it slurred his voice at the end of
the sentence closed his eyes and he died
the following evening
Sylvia jukes Morris has left her
husband's desk largely untouched the
books he was using at the time his
famous glasses hanging on the wall a
portrait of Theodore Roosevelt's
Morris's first biography the rise of
Theodore Roosevelt's one in the Pulitzer
Prize it was the first and a three-part
series on Roosevelt that stretched a
thousand pages longer than Warren piece
a remarkable accomplishment for a man
who up until his early 30s was working
as an advertising executive Morris
went on to write about Ronald Reagan's
life with unprecedented access to the
40th president this serves to introduce
Edmund Morris who's been authorized to
write the president's biography my
husband and I have full confidence in
mr. Morris as a historian and scholar
and ask that you give him every
assistance in his research from Nancy
Reagan but that book Dutch was heavily
criticized after Morris invented a
fictional character to move alongside
Reagan and tell his story in an
interview on 60 minutes in 1999 Morris
talked about his opinion of Reagan I do
not hide the fact that Reagan was
frequently an old spaced-out man in
attentive to details
I do not disguise the fact that he was
boring in private now that book was so
controversial how does all that sit with
you and how did it sit with him he'd
probably tell you it was favorite book
he would because he wanted to do
something different you say he said
biography so stick-in-the-mud in a way
it was sort of birth to death and that
of course got to the critics very
exercised what did you think of that
idea when he first said it well at first
I was horrified of course as this new
book is published it will become clear
Edmund Morris was not done shaking up
the world the biographies this time he
starts the book at the back and finishes
with Edison as a child a sort of
Benjamin Button tale that's another
thing we had words about I really don't
think you had enough trouble over Dutch
I said and now you're gonna do this now
you're gonna backwards I said oh that's
great but he he just like challenges he
liked to be different he was a little
bit of a maverick in that way it doesn't
paint a very flattering picture of
Edison as a person no because those
people are going to achieve anything
they've got to sacrifice a lot of their
personal life do you think that's sad or
do you think Edison didn't care I think
it's inevitable this is all Edison here
this is all Edison yes it really is
incredible edmund morris spent seven
years researching and wrestling with
every detail of Thomas Edison's life it
is illuminating extensive and a
memorable final contribution from an
author who will one day have books
written about him
what is Edmonds legis
I think his legacy will be a he was a
great biographer but also he was willing
to do something original hadn't been
done before I think that would be his
greatest pride in his work I don't want
to thank Silvia Jukes Morris for
spending time with us she was just so
wonderful and open talking about men
obviously it's been a very difficult
year for her but as this book is
released and others a lot to talk about
reflect on yes I have to tell you Edison
has been I've admired him for two things
one he was a great scientist open-minded
hired an african-american man because he
bested him in his invention of the light
bulb
he made it even better and so Lewis
Latimer is a known patent er and is is
now known to all of mankind it was all
about the team with Edison and that's
the approach that we have to that
team-based approach